you know when some people do prolong
fasting
they might end up with
various symptoms related to the
gallbladder and that would be right
shoulder pain or tightness that can go
into the right side of the neck through
here it can even cause jaw issues or
even a headache on the right side of the
head
nauseousness
bloating
a full feeling underneath the right rib
cage
or pain or tightness
or discomfort underneath the breastbone
and what's happening is the bile is
becoming a sludge okay it's called
biliary sludge or bile sludge
because the bile is becoming very very
thick because normally when you have the
right ratio of bile and cholesterol
everything's fine
but when the bile becomes deficient to a
certain degree
the concentration of cholesterol and
other things in bile become more
concentrated or super concentrated
and things start getting thicker and it
backs up to the pipes or tubes bile
ducts and that causes the symptoms that
i just mentioned the person may even
find that their cholesterol goes up
because one of the purposes of bile is
the elimination of cholesterol and they
may even notice on a blood test that
they have higher levels of bilirubin
or alkaline phosphatase that is just an
indication that there's some type of
problem with the gallbladder and it's
backing up into the liver now normally
this shouldn't happen when someone fast
unless
there is a pre-existing problem with
bile like a bile deficiency going into
the prolonged fast because what happens
normally when you eat the gallbladder
contracts
and it squeezes out the bile
but if you're not eating it doesn't
contract and the purpose of the
gallbladder is to concentrate
the bile but if there's a deficiency of
bile for some reason which i'll go
through those reasons
the person can start developing this
sludge that kind of backs up through
these little ducts so we should probably
get our ducks in a row another
definition of duct so i'm going to
explain this simple solution but
let's first just mention the things that
can cause a bile deficiency
well
bile is produced by your liver so if
there's any problem with the liver as in
a fatty liver
or an inflamed liver like hepatitis or a
liver that's filled with scar tissue as
in cirrhosis
that could be why you have a deficiency
in bile now also if you're on a statin
drug
that could be a reason because statins
work by blocking the production of
cholesterol and bile is made from
cholesterol
if you're on a low cholesterol or a
low-fat diet that can create a
deficiency in bile if you're eating a
diet that's spiking insulin or have high
insulin
that can create a bile deficiency if you
have high cortisol from stress that can
create a problem or high estrogen for
some reason maybe you're on birth
control pills or hormone replacement
therapy or you just became pregnant have
you ever heard about someone being
pregnant and then feeling nauseous
well that's the reason now also could be
that the person had gastric bypass
because that alters the release of bile
and that could be the problem another
problem is that if someone doesn't have
enough microbiome they don't have enough
friendly bacteria let's say they just
came off an antibiotic
and your microbes make bile so that
could be the reason why you're deficient
and one last very interesting reason why
someone can be bile deficient
they're on
like
an iv nutrition it's called parenteral
nutrition okay that has to do with
having an iv put nutrition into your
body versus consuming food that goes
through your digestive tract it doesn't
have anything to do with parenting or
being a parent so it's interesting about
parenteral nutrition
is that if someone is on this for
13 weeks or longer
based in one study a hundred percent of
the
patients
developed bile or bilirubi sludge
which by the way is the precursor to
gallstones i mean if you think about
what's in this nutrition it's just
terrible
50 of it is dextrose which is a
synthetic sugar they have soy oil which
is probably the worst omega-6 fatty acid
out there it's highly processed it
probably has hexane which is a solvent
and has been known to increase liver
enzymes as well as a fatty liver in
people taking parenteral nutrition and
then they add amino acids synthetic
vitamins minerals some trace minerals so
what is the solution
it's called tudka tutcom it's a type of
bile salt that i would highly recommend
that you can buy online i'm not going to
recommend a brand you have to find that
brand yourself based on maybe some good
reviews but cut is a type of bile salt
that thins the bile okay it will really
give you a lot of relief and you want to
take tutka on an empty stomach you want
to take two
and if it's very severe maybe you want
to take two on an empty stomach twice a
day in addition to that i would also
recommend taking bile salts with a meal
the one i'm going to recommend is called
gallbladder formula i will put a link
down below if you want more information
on that but this tutka remedy is
fascinating and i created a video on it
so you can see
all the other things it does check it
out i put it right here